hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to scp-087 be is gonna
be the last time that I play it so I've
already got all the tips from you guys
I've looked up how to beat it so I am
ready this game so much of the biggest
baby in the world when it comes to know
I'm a man I'm a man you can't scare me
if I'm screaming at you I can't hear you
screaming
okay all right so if I go down Matt
amazed they go down the wrong I got to
turn around and book it to try to get to
the other one as quick as possible
other than that just gotta keep moving
forward see the guy stop wait for him
come to me this game so much I hate it
so much
oh I hate it so much it is so much I
know about the hole in the wall some i
some I'm supposed to look into it or not
depending on what he says so I know I
know some guys have been saying that
it's not that based on actual CPOs
southern because this you know brick and
it's not really stairwell but still I
don't think that even matters at this
point 11 fudge
just keep moving forward cheer me on
guys everyone can hear your comments
from the future
oh I get the worst goosebumps everything
everything is so bad I hate my eyes I
hate my life I know things only happens
until 17 I think I'm going til I get 17
oh no mate all right no monster fun okay
man
I've commented before but for such a
small game so so let me don't get me
wrong 10 out of 10 but awful 16 another
one let's write this up okay I'll try
left next time no I'm coming up with 17
no no no no no you listen this is 17
losses the exact if different not a baby
I'm a man
nothing's happening I can do that too
that's not something you start early
it's awesome I saw something I saw
something ok I can handle this
Oh God jump mother it's that face that
face I put on the videos it's in the
face
hi fish oh my my face is a bad place
it's a bad face ugly face you were ugly
you still ugly and fat and stupid yeah
that's right that's right
you feel ugly yeah dude poor dr.
Shephard mom is dead
I don't even know that makes sense I
can't go laughing don't be wrong
okay all right yay oh I hate this game
so I'm sweating oh my god my arms are
like my arms are like sweaty my palm I
think okay going out of my mind
26 I think this is the most I've ever
been done you're good I'm doing great
oh no not again
oh no not again not again not again ah
don't kill me bro
he's toying with me
whoa a lit-up hallway like what up I
know what that was
oh no I was no no I don't know I don't
know I'm about hit 30 I think 30 so far
as I've ever been
keep moving water
keep moving mark fly you got this hmm oh
God just a break I'm crazy
three two again I know how to beat you
now know how to beat you now come from
behind me
for a second there I know how to beat
this guy now how to beat him shut up
that's nothing shut up that's nothing
nothing is that things went weird my
face is going too well blurry I think
that might have been the monster in the
window
oh no right no not again
stop it why do I keep getting so many
wrong answers oh no I think I might even
a monster in that window and if I had
looked at it I would have died I think I
didn't say anything
so No
ah I was doing so good
oh I didn't see me pee
Oh huh this has got to be the last time
guys that's got to be last time I
believe that I can't take it anymore I
can't take it I'm getting better at it
don't get me wrong I'm getting better at
it but oh man oh I came down something
to me
bad things anyway I hope you enjoyed it
make fun of me in the comments all you
wanna it's gonna take a lot of
convincing to make me play that again or
they're gonna have to come up with a new
version or I totally panicked at the end
there I did I did I didn't hear I hadn't
heard that noise before and it sounded
like it was behind me and my headphones
so I was like I didn't see it in front
of me so it's just like I'll go forward
and then maybe I didn't go forward
that's enough indica I don't know I
don't know what happened there this the
thing I didn't see anything
Oh God
anyway hoo-boy all right
the things I do for you yes oh man
anyway I love you guys who died but
anyway thank you all so much for
watching I do appreciate you senator
Clinton and as always I will see you in
the next video bye-bye